this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
today we have a special guest in the
studio matthiavella is here
aka the italian styling that is true
i did not come up with that i just want
to make the record clear that was
something that you guys gave
me as a nickname and i have not forced
you to say that
okay i confirm that that piece of
information thank you
your money will be in the mail today
we're going to talk about success we're
going to talk about habit change we're
going to talk about letting go of stuff
and of course we're going to talk about
our new film
yeah which is out this friday woo
congratulations matthiavella good work
man
to you guys what the heck
four years later i know it took so long
well actually
that let's talk about that real quick by
the way the new film it's on netflix
this friday january 1st 2021 it's called
les
is now it's a documentary it's a special
it's a docu-special
it's all of these things it's none of
these things
and matt when you were editing the film
there was a line initially at the
beginning the very first line in fact
was while we were on the road
and it was me talking to ryan or someone
and
i said you know we've been doing this
for the last six years and i and i
emailed you like matt we have to like
overdub this line or something this film
it's ten years now and you're like and
you just
emailed me back and you said the moment
i realized i've been working on a film
for four years
it definitely catches up to you i think
that uh this project was certainly
unique in that
uh it has evolved so much since the very
beginning
like i think the core structure of the
film like the message and everything
that
really ended up becoming the film is
still there
um but we had to kind of have a go at it
two or three times before we really
found it
um i mean i think that i don't think we
could have imagined it coming out as
good as it did
when we first started and i and i think
i'm just glad that we didn't settle
because it would have been easy to say
all right this version
is good enough let's just ship it and i
think that's difficult for
any creative or any filmmaker to really
know what the difference is and
how to not get stuck in perfectionism
but i think we found the right balance
and we got the right feedback early on
from the right people
um and we also just trusted our gut to
be able to say all right we need to keep
working at this thing until it's right
and you know it took four years but i'm
glad it did
yeah yeah the uh the first two or three
versions
it was like you know you did an amazing
job with the footage we gave you
but my gut was like yeah this is this is
okay like this will pass this will pass
and then
you know however many versions later
like now i watch it and i'm like oh yeah
this is good
like i feel really really good about it
and we've been through this before yeah
the first documentary yeah so it wasn't
new territory
um and i think any time it's very
different from doing the youtube videos
or even a podcast like we create all the
time
where you you create and you ship you
create and you ship and you keep going
but when you're creating a piece that
you want to last hopefully a lifetime
hopefully
for the next couple decades to impact
people's lives
it's really worth it to make sure you're
doing it in a way that you feel
happy with and you feel like is really
going to resonate with people yeah it's
hard to um
compare it to minimalism or first
documentary and it's not
i don't really compare less is now with
minimalism but what i do compare is how
i feel
about the movie and i'll tell you with
with minimalism the very first
uh cut that he sent i was like oh man
like
i don't know how he did it but there's a
story here and it's amazing and it was
really uh it was just really moving
um and that's the feeling that you know
i was hoping to get from this
film and it wasn't until like these last
two or three cuts that i finally started
to get that where i'm like oh yes we did
it
yeah yeah and i would say too that like
there was a lot at stake there was a bit
of pressure because
we are telling your story in a way that
hasn't been told before
and this is something like a message
that you've been sharing for
you said over the past decade right and
so yeah a lot of that story is in
minimalism but this goes deeper into a
new level that we haven't yet brought to
light and so
i think we just really wanted to make
sure that we told your story in a way
that um was true and accurate and that
would actually help people who watch it
dude you killed it man bravo i mean i'm
really excited for it
it was a team effort that's what i say
yeah and we'll talk about the whole team
because it's not just the three of us
for sure there's an entire team behind
this whether it's tim and jacob and
chris and
i mean everyone who worked on sound i
want to talk about the the
and everything else there's so many
people you'll have to see the end
credits to see how many people actually
worked on this thing i do want to talk
about the process though
because it started as one thing we we
kind of figured like
hey you know what this is beginning of
2017.
we'll just knock this out in about four
months
so the first iteration you were actually
you came out and we filmed
in well all throughout the northeast but
ballston at the wilbur theater in
particular so let's talk about that
first iteration of this film
well i think it's funny because in the
beginning we
started out very similar to how we
started out minimalism which was
let's grab a camera let's hit the road
and let's just see what we capture
and that happened to work really well
for minimalism but we were
planning on shooting a different
documentary one that was really focused
on
this structural monologue this piece
where you guys are sharing your story in
a very raw way and talking about
that journey and so when we went out and
hit the road uh it started to feel a
little bit too much
like the last film and we also wanted to
figure out ways how can we elevate this
story how can we make it different
and unique and so you know part of that
was just capturing
the talk that you guys gave in these
live environments
one of them was the wilbur i mean from a
very technical perspective i think one
of the biggest mistakes was like
well one we just didn't really invest a
lot into it it was almost as if we
spread our investments out over a bunch
of different shoots whereas just two of
us
traveling around yeah for a couple weeks
just capturing what we could
and that's raw and it's gritty and it
works but like if you're doing a film
that's really like
telling this story in a way that's a
monologue where you're delivering
a large part of it to the camera it's
really
it it's better to take all those
resources and compact it down to a
couple days
and as you guys know that eventually led
to a couple weeks of really intense
production days where we had 12 hour
production days for like two weeks
straight where
we really captured all these stories i
mean it was just so cool to be able to
rebuild it and i don't know how you guys
felt
about it but and i don't know how much
we can really talk about i'm sure that
some of it's gonna be in the trailer
but this idea of like the going back and
revisiting
your past and going back to the
corporate offices
and going back to like your childhood
homes and recreating those elements
i don't know how you guys felt about
that but i it for me i was like a bit
emotional because
i've been hearing your guys story for so
long and then here we are rebuilding it
and retelling that story
um it felt very real to me yeah no i
totally agree
i found that as we were going through
that whole process we were kind of
uncovering
what this film was going to be we had an
initial conception maybe not an
expectation
but that changed considerably over the
course of the last four years so
we went out we filmed some live events
that didn't really work it wasn't our
didn't capture the right aesthetic and
so we did it again back in 20
it wasn't 19 beginning of 2019 we
rented a abandoned warehouse and in
south central la we brought
300 people out twice and gave the talk
built a stage and gave this talk in a
different space
and it still it still didn't feel like
what we were trying to create in fact
the metaphor i've used is because we
wanted to use the talk mixed with these
documentary
aspects i felt really good about what we
filmed with the talk
it felt to me like a delicious piece of
salmon
and then the documentary elements felt
like this
great piece of chocolate cake and you
just mixed them together
and it was salmon chocolate cake and it
just it didn't work how did you
eventually figure out the way to make it
work
i think like anything it takes creating
and then
iterating you have to make that first
version
and then really gut check yourself and i
think this came from all of us really
sitting back and watching the film over
and over again and really thinking about
how we can make this thing better so
yeah the first version
was shot with two people in at the
wilbur theater in boston
and it was really flat and like
two-dimensional and there really wasn't
a lot there
like terrible audio their one camera was
a red which the quality looked good but
the other cameras were like these like
low rate dslr cameras and so
that didn't work we eventually shot in
this warehouse great cameras but
it was very do it yourself and so for me
it felt like
a cheap special like it didn't feel like
it was truly special
and so we just you know i think one
part of that is is us never really doing
something like this before
um and also using a very limited budget
so there's a reason why
comedy specials cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars to make right
is because like it really takes that
much money to hire the right crew to
hire the right cameras to really put
together
a team uh that's going to actually make
something that's at that production
level
and that was different from the first so
the first home we had zero budget
initially going into the film right and
this one we at first we're trying to
shoestring it but
what we realized is that as you said it
requires the whole
team to make this and so i think we
ended up
and i can't divulge the number because
of contracts and stuff but
we spent more on this film than i've
ever spent on
anything that we've ever produced yeah
at this point
um and it none of it was frivolous it
was still very
frugal with respect to everything we
were doing but
it required something different because
this film is not
just the the josh and ryan story it's
not that at all you did so much more in
terms of
expanding it to
ryan and i are in it but it applies it
feels like everyone's story in a way
yeah yeah and i think that uh to go on
that trajectory the
we had that the film that was shot in a
warehouse from us and and
it was okay but then that's when we
decided like
i think that this can be a lot better
but we just need the budget we just need
the the resources to be able to make
that happen
yeah um and so then that's when we uh
approach netflix and we're like hey
this is what we shot we know it's not
great but we have a vision for what it
could be
and if you see the same vision that we
do then i think we can really take this
to the next level
and to their credit they saw the vision
through the dust
and then we ended up um teaming up and
then this
that's how it became a netflix original
because they bought into this idea
and then with that budget we were able
to just put everything into these
productions to
yes to shoot the monologue in a really
beautiful warehouse with amazing cameras
and lights and all that stuff and a
great crew that was
just incredible to work with yeah and
then on top of that we were able to add
these documentary elements where we
interview experts and we
really dive deeper into this problem
than we ever had a chance to with
minimalism totally
yeah i'm really grateful for netflix how
they saw our vision and they helped us
bring it to fruition
they've been awesome to work with yeah
well the film is out january one kick
off your new year with less it's called
less is now we're going to talk a lot
more about it on the maximal episode
we're also going to
talk to matt about our history together
we've got a bunch of questions about the
film
for the maximal episode as well but i
want to dive into some of these
audience questions here today our first
question is from katherine
in san marcos texas i'm a professional
singer and voice
teacher and i would call myself a
minimalist
i've already shedded things in my life
that don't add any value
there are a couple of things that i do
need
to have in order to teach my students
and
in order to be a musician in general and
some of those things
are a full size 88 key
keyboard which is quite big and quite
heavy
and also a collection of song books that
i
can't really digitize because i need to
be able to write in them
and my students need to be able to have
physical books to work out of
to be honest i'm a little frustrated
that i can't get rid of these items
they absolutely add value to my life i
mean i need them
in order to do what i do but i'm finding
myself
getting rid of things right and left and
i'm wondering if i'm starting to develop
an
unhealthy obsession with just getting
rid of things
what advice would you give to someone
who
is a minimalist but needs certain things
in order to do
you know whatever it is that they do
maybe a mechanic who has a bunch of
tools
a musician who has a piano any advice
there and
am i going too far with wanting to just
get rid of everything so matt it seems
to me like we often confuse minimalism
with asceticism or or or deprivation
in a way and i think that's where
catherine is right now
what would you tell someone like this
you get people are commenting like
this all the time on your youtube
channel they're they're searching
they're
exploring and they're wondering uh
am i going too far yeah i think
catherine is not going far enough i
think she needs to get rid of the
keyboard get rid of the books get rid of
the students
you call yourself a minimalist catherine
um no i mean
obviously i go through this as a
filmmaker i mean i think if you looked
at my gear closet you would say this guy
is absolutely not a minimalist
he has four cameras and so many
different lenses and
cards and little pieces of gear it's
funny you guys talk a lot about just in
case and i think
for most people that's absolutely true
you you do not need to hold on to just
in case items
but for plumbers and electricians and
filmmakers
there's a lot of little gadgets and
little pieces of gear
that if you didn't have it on the shoot
there's so many different problems that
you need to solve in the middle of a
shoot where oh i need this piece of gear
that's going to connect to this
and you're often like being very
resourceful with the gear that you have
and so i think that um sometimes we do
need to have those things that we use
once or twice a year
i mean with the case of the keyboard and
with the books and stuff
those are absolutely essential like that
she needs those to be able to do what
she does
and same for me i have camera gear that
i
absolutely need now there are always
going to be those things that
that are kind of on the fringe right you
have the essential you have what you
absolutely need for me personally
to make a video i need a camera i need a
lens i need a memory card a battery
a computer editing software and like
these are like the physical items that i
need to actually make a video
but then you have the extra things you
have the gimbal
you have the drone you have the fog
machine you have all these extra things
that might make your videos cooler a
little bit better
and i think it really takes you being
honest with yourself about
the kind of projects that you want to
work on and it does sometimes
require you to make mistakes for
instance i have a fog machine
i bought this fog machine because for a
couple videos right like you buy it
because oh it's gonna work really well
for this and then
you also come up with these excuses and
reasons for why it's gonna work for
every other video that you're gonna work
on in the future
and so i think it's okay to make
mistakes it's okay to buy something that
you maybe thought you
you were going to need but then you have
to revisit that and as you guys say all
the time as our lives changes the things
that we need
change as well and so we need to be able
to reassess that in three months or six
months and say hey
do i actually still need this thing and
if not can i find somebody else who
can actually get more value from it no
you don't confuse what i love about you
is you don't confuse the tools with the
craft
for you those tools they amplify or
enhance
what you're doing but too often we get
really excited about a thing
everyone was 18 years old once or 15
they started a business but really they
bought a stapler and some file folders
and some business cards and they started
a business without
actually doing the things required to
create
you create and then you use tools to
augment that
in fact i would not call those just in
case items i would call them just for
win items
and i'd like to make that distinction
because there are some things like you
don't buy your toilet paper one
square at a time or your toothpaste one
nerdle at a time you buy
a a a an entire tube or several tubes at
a time
because that makes sense and you're
going to use it just for when but i'm
sure there's some film equipment that
you have now that you
will find out you're not using and then
you'll let it go
yeah i'm actually in the process of
doing that right now and revisiting a
lot of my gear you know i've got a
couple gopros
and a drone there's some things that we
think that we need but eventually it
turns out that we were fooling ourselves
and that's where you have to be honest
with yourself
um i think it would be helpful i mean
there's also
hundreds of things that i maybe thought
i needed that i didn't buy
and i think that that's important
because we really want to be responsible
when it comes to the environment and the
things that we're consuming and think
about all the packages that you had to
open up and all that stuff that you had
to throw away or recycle
um and so i i think really it's it's
about looking at it in the long run
being really smart with our decisions
um i understand what catherine is saying
too about she said sometimes
you just get so excited about that
decluttering process and getting rid of
things and like
having as few items as possible that
holding on to a big bulky keyboard or
i mean i i sometimes get frustrated with
my own thing like i actually
had 40 or 50 hard drives all this
huge amount of hard drives like it took
up so much space in my closet
it was probably like 40 probably about
70 terabytes worth of footage
and like and also we're talking about
this is technology that was 10 years old
and so like the two terabyte drives are
just as big as the 20 terabyte drives
now
and so uh i recently went through this
process like that's been so frustrating
for me as a minimalist to have it
and so i recently went through and i'm
like all right can i actually start to
take these hard drives and put them down
onto even smaller drives and consolidate
that stuff
but over the years you just you can find
a place to store it you can find a place
to organize it if you absolutely need
the thing
um and hopefully that takes away from
that that uh disappointment of having
that extra clutter around the house
but truly it's not really clutter if
you're actually getting value from it
totally no i love uh
how your story really speaks to how
minimalism is not this like end
destination it is this tool
that we use to constantly uh
uh uh uh what's what i'm looking for i
want to say pared down in our life but
it's more than that it's it's
cultivating a meaningful life
so you know catherine yeah like if the
stuff that you have right now
if it's appropriate for you great but
tomorrow it might not be appropriate for
you oh and by the way
the deck the next day after that you
might need to buy something else to
uh to enhance whatever it is that you're
doing um no i think it's a great story i
think often about the red camera that
you had
yeah about how it was um this amazing
camera you were like you know this is it
and we used it a lot and then it got to
a point where you were like
i don't need this red camera yeah it
wasn't even red it was black
it was a black camera yeah the logo was
red though um but yeah it was um you
know that's
really one of the top of the line cinema
cameras that you can buy i spent like 38
thousand dollars on it
it was a massive investment and um and
it was also a write-off for my business
and so but uh that was when i was doing
freelance i had a freelance filmmaking
business i was working with corporate
clients we were making films
but then i started a youtube channel and
then when i started the youtube channel
i realized
this is actually slowing me down because
the file sizes are so big
it's a it's a complicated camera to work
and to edit with
and i realized if i actually simplified
and i got a camera
that was a fraction of the price and
also i like i want to make it clear
any aspiring filmmakers or any creatives
like you're going to feel like oh i need
that 30 000. that for whatever like the
really expensive camera
because it's going to make my videos so
much better i have seen
really no difference in terms of quality
from the camera that i quote unquote
downgraded to
in fact it's actually made allowed me to
move a lot quicker and a lot faster
and so more expensive isn't always
better yeah
what i love about that is sometimes what
we realized the things we thought we
needed the tools that we needed
they slow us down they get in the way
they're actually preventing us from
creating the thing we want to create
because we're spending time sort of
maintaining this
this facade well i've got the red camera
that's why you should hire me
right as opposed to well no i'm a great
filmmaker that's why you should hire me
i'm going to help you
execute your vision that's why you
should hire me
and so what what you've identified there
is that sometimes the things that we
think we need the question i've been
asking a lot
of not just things but commitments
obligations relationships recently is
does this bring tranquility or does it
increase my well-being
and if not we should certainly let it go
and the case of the red for you
is no it it didn't bring you tranquility
it brought you the opposite it was it
added stress and so letting go of that
is the thing that brought you more
tranquility in a way yeah and i think
i'm sure that you guys know this
firsthand that constraints are often
really powerful form
of bringing creativity to life and so
when you
we have constraints in everything we do
if you're a freelancer working on a
project
there is the brief that the client gives
you and that's the guidelines that you
have to follow
and when you limit yourself with the
amount of gear that you can have
say if you try to only create a video on
the absolute essentials just what you
need
in many ways you'll find out that yes
you can move a lot quicker
you have to get more creative with
certain shots you might not have a crane
to do an overhead
shot so maybe you have to like gaff tape
something up or you need to like rig
something together that will work or you
just change the angle
there are workarounds and there's
different things that you can do uh but
it really
i i'm actually experimenting that with a
little bit more
myself now as i start to pare down some
of my older gear
realizing that maybe some of the things
that i thought i needed uh
or were just wants or they were nice to
haves
and so i think as any kind of creative
these are the the questions you're going
to have to deal with on a regular basis
yeah catherine um we talked about a
couple rules here today the justin case
rule the just for win rule those are two
separate rules
and we've got 16 of those rules in the
minimalist rule book it's free you can
download it at theminimalists.com
rulebook there's an audiobook version
available over there as well
but if you just want the free download
there's 16 rules for living
with less the minimalists.com rulebook
i think you'll find some value in those
rules julio from connecticut has a
question
i feel like i'm at a fork in the road
and i don't exactly know which
path to go down i'm 27
single debt free with a nice financial
cushion
i just moved back in with my parents
after living and working in london
so i want to pursue acting specifically
acting for film
the past few years i have been acting in
some indie films and i really believe
that acting is what i'm meant to do i
was a theater major in college but i
know that going to grad school on top of
that degree
would give me the formal training and
professional connections that could
really propel me forward in my career
so one path is a very expensive
but rewarding grad school education the
other path i see
is to pick up and move to another city
start over and pursue a career in acting
without further education
so matt you know what's fascinating here
about julia's question
is she said so many things here by the
way congratulations 27
being debt-free it's incredible amazing
that's awesome
you because you're not tethered to
anything right now so the options you
have
are good options right now of course
you're
debt-free and one of those options is
you're saying maybe i want to take on
some debt
now i would think about that i'm going
to throw one thing out there matt i want
to hear you respond to this she said
that she feels like acting
is what she was meant to do i don't
think you were meant to do
anything i don't think you're born to be
a filmmaker for example
i think greatness comes from a strong
desire the reason
matt is a great filmmaker and i mean
that truly matt you are a
phenomenal filmmaker greatness comes
from a desire
it's not like if you didn't have the
desire to tell stories to make films
you would you'd become great at
something else
that you truly desired and so a bunch of
practice acting isn't what makes you
great it's the desire to act that
leads to the practice that makes you
great um
yeah i think that she is i
i i think that she's very fortunate in
that she knows
where she wants to head in life the
direction that she wants to head i think
so many people
are in this conflicted area where
they're looking for purpose and i think
especially now during covid
if there's one thing that's bringing to
light what's truly most important in
life obviously relationships are health
but finding a purpose and having
something that really fulfills us
is truly important so it's amazing that
she's found that i think that
it's yes it's the desire you need the
drive to want to do it
i think to answer her question whether
she needs to take on this
debt or not i would definitely
say no please please do not go into debt
i graduated college with
uh 97 000 in student loans and then i
bought a brand new car
and so then i was about 117 000 in debt
and i can't tell you just the amount of
weight that put on my shoulders and also
how much it limited me in the
decisions that i could take going
forward there was the anxiety and the
stress of every bill that came in
i'm talking 700 every month in payments
that i had to pay off
oh my god and i knew that if if i didn't
make a change at that moment then i
would have to be paying this off for the
next 20 years
imagine having those expenses for 20 30
years
and so definitely do anything you can to
avoid that situation
and now it's easier than ever to to be
able to get the education you need and
make the contacts and the connections
that you need
um outside of going to college and
outside of getting a college degree
um i would say even so filmmaking you
learn to
make films not from what you did in
college necessarily
but from actually doing the work it's
like imagine
imagine michael jordan michael jordan
going to basketball college
yeah yeah it would be like what are you
doing oh yeah i need to read the
textbook about
about how to dribble the history of
basketball yeah it's like
those things are nice to know the the
the history of
of what you're doing what you're
pursuing but
acting or filmmaking or playing
basketball
it's about doing and the most you've
learned from
is actually camera in hand doing the
work
right yeah yeah i was gonna say do you
think you could be where you are now if
you
didn't go to college like hindsight
would you have been like
oh hindsight do you think like oh maybe
i shouldn't have gone and taken that
degree
i'm just curious you know obviously
looking back
it worked out right like going to
college
i i wouldn't wish that kind of debt on
anybody
i got the college experience which
wasn't what it was all cracked up to be
and then going out partying drinking and
doing all that
um you know it was one of those things
that i felt like i had to do at the time
but
uh it certainly now i i could have lived
without it
and also you can go out party and drink
yeah without
paying 97 000 exactly yeah like you
could do all these things like
me making connections i mean the
connections that i made while i was in
college that allowed me to grow my
business initially make the connections
that i did
that eventually led me to meeting you
guys like there's this snowball of
connections that you make early on in
your younger adulthood that lead as long
as you
um are genuine and you're open and
you're authentic
and you are as a creative or a filmmaker
whatever it is
delivering to your clients those
connections will continue to flourish
and spread to others
if you start cutting off bridges and you
start like really disrupting those
relationships
then you're not going to see as many
opportunities in the future
but uh yeah like i i i mean there are
very few
if any obviously i made lots of great
friends in college but very few
relationships that have
stuck through to this day professionally
or personal
the connections that i did make were
that eventually like led to these
connections today were all from people
that i met outside of school
and josh your point earlier uh you know
i definitely i always tell people don't
let
your syllabus dictate like what you
learn and what you do like you really
have to learn outside of the classroom
yeah and i think that early on in
college like if you look at those videos
especially compared to what i'm doing
now he's terrible like he hasn't like
he's not going to go anywhere with this
thing but compared to a lot of people
that were
at my age at that time like in schools
they weren't um a lot of kids 95
of people weren't applying themselves
outside of the classroom they were just
following the syllabus what the teacher
told them to do that's what they were
doing
but it was that desire and that drive
like i just love to create and if you
love to create if you love acting
then pour yourself into that there are
so it's so much better
to do it yourself to find these small
productions to work on
yeah than to try to follow the
traditional route because the
traditional route is crumbling like the
gatekeepers are falling away
right and you need to really make your
own path if you really want to make it
in the industry and by make it
i mean create a sustainable income doing
what you love i think that's like the
goal for most creatives right
whether you're a stand-up comedian or an
actress or actor
like you just want to do what you love
and get paid a decent
salary doing it that's a great point so
julia uh please don't go into debt
because if you do go into debt when you
come out of college
it's not going to be a get to it's going
to be a have to you're going to have to
make money from this
in order to pay off your debt and that
is a really good way to to kill your
passion or or
to kill your dream one thing i'll add
here too julia uh i have a lot of um
actor friends um they're you know not
major i guess lily gladstone's a pretty
major actress
um but uh long story short i have talked
to them about going
to school for acting because i love to
act i've been in a couple plays
and the way i describe myself as a very
good amateur
and uh i actually told a director that
once uh during a reading i was like i
just want to let you know like i'm an
amateur but i'm a really good amateur
and he laughed and chuckled and then we
started getting into the play he's like
you're exactly what you said you were
like you are a very good amateur
self-awareness right exactly exactly but
but uh talking to my friends about going
to acting school
just to um learn how to act they really
every i'm not not one of them has said
yeah you should do that at some point
and
uh yeah you should go for four years and
get your acting degree or whatever it is
uh what they have suggested is finding
an acting coach
that that i connect with and that's
really how
uh you can pursue your career julia
without
going into a crazy amount of debt like f
find an acting coach
make sure that you two click and then
you can certainly uh
get better at acting but please don't go
in the dead julia i just think we too
often we confuse
schooling with education and one does
not necessarily equate to the other
credentials often lead to mediocrity
yeah we didn't we didn't become friends
tweet that podcast sean
we didn't become friends with matt
because he's a certified filmmaker right
you know it's like
that doesn't matter your credentials
often
just mean that you learn you got the
certificate
you learned what was in the textbook but
it doesn't mean that you
did what was necessary to create
something that is elite or great
yeah and i think that is true with any
profession the last thing i'll say for
julia and anyone else is
if you find the thing that you love
that you really enjoy doing
that is fun that is not fun to other
people
that is the place in which you will
thrive if it is a game
for you to become the best actor right
because for me that would be miserable
being a a director
would would not be the thing i want to
do either it's not the game that i want
to play
so to speak right and so i'm just i
would be discontented doing something
like that
now matt i do want to talk to you about
this on the the actually if we have time
on the the maximal
i think we'll cover it there was a time
when i remember you were first started
on your own and
you're a filmmaker but then you started
like blogging and doing these other
things that weren't
weren't your thing necessarily because
you saw someone else's path and you're
like i think i'll
i'll try this and when we do them we
play someone else's game i think it
often leads to discontent
yeah that was uh i mean really when i
made the transition
from it was right after we finished
minimalism
i up until that point i was a freelance
filmmaker filmmaker i worked with
nothing but
clients and amazing clients but i knew i
was ready for a change
and i'd always want to be an original
content creator whatever that was i
always wanted to be able to
create something myself and hopefully
establish an audience that would be
happy to pay for it or watch it
consume it and so uh yeah the first
thing i did was because i was such a fan
of bloggers
uh and essayists like you guys i was
like oh okay like i'm gonna start a blog
and that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
and like it was okay but i i got like
four posts in
and then i just ran out of fuel and i
was like okay
actually what am i doing here i this is
not who i
am or this is not what really drives me
the most
and that's when i started to lean into
filmmaking and i was like all right well
let me do some podcasting and make
videos and then eventually
started making youtube videos and it's
funny how like i wanted to
experiment which was great and i
definitely recommend everybody
experiment with different things and
tinker around to find out what you truly
love to do
but i just found my way back to
filmmaking because
you know call it a call and call it a
drive or desire that's just what i love
to do
um and so i think it's you'll find it
and like you'll know
like you if you keep giving up within
four days of starting something new
um then it might not be for you yeah
that drive that's pushing you to keep
going
for sure you started over in a way it
wasn't a
well it was i mean it was completely
different from what you were doing
before with the client work the
corporate work
it was filmmaking but it was a different
kind of creating it was creating for you
not creating based upon the visions and
expectations of
of other people necessarily and i love
that the starting over thing ryan when
you were a kid growing up and
and you probably like to build some
things with legos or
blocks or whatever but was do you
remember the most fun part at least for
me
destroying the legos exactly
that that's exactly it and and i think
in a way
we actually enjoy the destruction
more than we enjoy the creation here's
what i mean by that
we need to find a healthy destruction
because many of us destroy things
because we
will go out and do opioids or we would
drink ourselves to a stupor or whatever
yeah that's a that is not a helpful
destruction but like i think about when
you and i walked away from the corporate
world
yeah we sort of destroyed that old life
and in many ways it was more enjoyable
than creating that life
was right totally and so i think you
know
julia's at a crossroads right now she's
starting over yeah julie i'm gonna send
you a copy of
our book everything that remains it's my
favorite book that we've
written and it is a story of me and ryan
starting over this five year journey of
uh ryan and i
be being these suit and tie corporate
guys becoming the minimalist first time
we met matt is he filmed the book
trailer for that back in 2013.
dude that was that was so well i mean i
just love the story of how
we got to be matt's friends we're going
to talk about that on the maximum
yeah yeah talk about yeah just talk
about car
making your own path i mean that's such
a good story all right i won't spoil it
well uh julia i hope you enjoy
everything that remains if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of that book or if you want the
book book or the ebook we're happy to
send those to you as well ryan what time
is it you know what time it is it is
time for our lightning round where we
answer your text
messages you can text your questions and
comments
directly to joshua melbourne's phone
that phone number is
two four 937-20246 five four those texts
actually go to both of our phones
um and we do personally respond to as
many people as we can we just share a
phone
cause we're minimalist yes it doesn't
have any buttons either
make sure you sanitize it i'm sorry i
derailed you
yeah well so um yeah we use this app
called community ryan and i get the text
they go
right to our phone we respond to a lot
of people we also respond to some folks
on the podcast now matt you know this
during the lightning round this is where
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so people can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if they'd like and by the way you can
find all of our minimal maxims in one
place now
minimal minimalmaxims.com we have a
question from mason mason wants to know
what advice do you have for someone
that's just
starting out that wants to have a
successful
film career like you like you matt yeah
this is me yeah because you you don't
actually be piffy you could mom
i was just thinking it would be funny
like do you guys always put it in the
in the show notes even if it's bad
because then i'm like just going to say
something ridiculous
and then you have to quote it and then
people who are looking at the website
what the heck is this
well if it's really if it's really dumb
we'll bleep it and we'll say it was
profound yeah and we'll make something
up
yeah we could only share it on patreon
oh yeah that's right
okay if you want to be a successful
filmmaker
um if you want to be a success you want
to be a successful filmmaker
like like you like you that's it
yeah are you talking about me yes you
know maybe another way to look at this
matt
is like when you think about that
college kid even before you got out of
college like
what would what advice would you give
yourself when you were
at that point in your life well i think
if you want to find success
in any field you need to first define
what success is
that's that's it that's good no but like
really like you you have to figure out
what because he's like saying like if
you want to be successful like me
it really depends like a lot of times
what
it looks like i do isn't
actually what i do because like you see
like if you love my youtube videos or
you love
the um like the films that i make the
feeling that you get when
when you watch that isn't necessarily
the feeling that i have when i'm making
it
right it's still like a thrill i love
doing it it's creative problem solving
but you really need to make sure that
you actually love the process of
filmmaking and whatever part of that
process it is whether it's the editing
or the directing or the filming
i happen to love all of it and so i
think you really have to make sure that
if you love what you do then i really
think that that's success and so
i mean it just takes ooh that's a good
pity one too if you love what you do
that's success yeah yeah that's great
it's good well matt
let me talk to you about that real quick
because i i and maybe it's a
generational thing ryan and i are
cuspers right we're
technically gen x or ryan is the
the youngest gen xer i know um
or it is true or he's the oldest
millennial i know yeah one or the other
yeah and or maybe i'm the oldest
millennial i just claim whatever is
convenient that day is what i claim well
here's the thing what i've noticed
people younger than me and ryan
and the younger it gets especially like
like
young millennials older gin z folks
they they define success by numbers
because we have
we've created a metric for everything
and when andrew schultz was on here he
goes i don't understand why jay-z wants
to be a billionaire
like now you're just the brokest
billionaire yeah
he's like or if you just convert if you
convert those dollars to
pounds now you're not a billionaire
anymore yeah
it also i think it's also like when we
see that when we see the numbers and i
know i certainly felt this way
like when you see somebody who has two
million or three million subscribers on
youtube
you think that that's like a feeling
like they have a
oh like now i have two million or three
but like whatever like you think it's
gonna
actually solve all of your problems and
i think this is like what we hear a lot
with people who
uh make a lot of money they realize that
oh i made all this money and i realized
it didn't make me happy yeah
so many people say well of course like
it's nice for you to say that because
you have all the money
but jim carrey said like who else is
going to be able to say that from
somebody who's experienced it and
realize it actually doesn't bring
happiness
right and like i can tell you firsthand
uh having zero subscribers and three
million
yes it allows me certain things it
allows me to create videos and like it's
amazing but like
i don't it doesn't change who you are it
shouldn't like
maybe there are some people who build up
these big followings and then their ego
gets inflated but i would say that those
people probably had egos to begin with
yeah
and that that following didn't help them
are you any happier at 3 million than
you were at 1 million or
2 million no i think that like obviously
like over the past couple years though
like i've had
ups and downs and like i've had to deal
with the the struggles of like the
pressure of creating for an audience
that wants to hear from you
and sometimes it's made you i mean just
based on your videos it's made you less
tranquil yeah it's decreased your
well-being because of chasing those
numbers right
yeah and not even intentionally chase
him and i will say matt it hasn't
changed you at all and i love that about
you
who you are as a person but there are
you felt some additional
pressure that probably decreased your
well-being yeah i think that that's like
if it did change me it added more stress
anxiety and pressure
which like that's what uh quote-unquote
like the typical measures of success can
do
and um so i think that uh for me and
also like it does come to a degree and i
know that you guys feel this as well
when you love your work you pour
yourself into it
and it's hard to find that line of like
overworking and then burnout and like
how do i manage this and i think the
added pressure of people waiting to hear
from you maybe made that worse for me
and so you know just like we were
talking about earlier like minimalism is
about
you continue to ask yourself these
questions about what you need and it
changes over time
you have to continue to check in with
yourself uh as a creator or as somebody
who's building an online following to
make sure that you're not doing it for
the metrics and you don't feel like you
have to do it
and that you actually want to do it
that's one of my favorite things about
netflix is they don't share the metrics
with us
yeah like i know just because of how
often people recognize
us from the first film i know a lot of
people saw it but i
i can't tell you whether it was 30
million or
70 million like and it doesn't really
matter i don't feel any more successful
today
in 2021 than
i did in 2011 because
success for me had
involved a certain amount of freedom and
and being financially free being
untethered
to obligations being unattached
to the desires desire is great
attachment
is suffering though right my pithy
answer for mason is no one can be a
better you than you
and i think that one of the problems we
seek is like hey how can i be matt
diabella well if you want to be an off
brand matt diavela
you could there are plenty of them out
there they come up in my youtube
all the time oh it's nice i like it
i find it flattering hi i'm i'm that mia
the funny thing i see is like someone
tries to make videos like matt
and they use like our rules without a it
so it's like
they're taking the minimalist sort of
written philosophy yeah
they try to mimic matt's style and it
just comes off as like
it's a great point it's like you're
eating at a a fake
mcdonald's like a north korean
mcdonald's or something it's like
what this is i think yeah it's okay to
be inspired and i think that some
sometimes people confuse what maybe is
the thing so whether it's like
copying thumbnails and like i certainly
pulled tons of inspiration when i
started from other people and like
what was going to work for the thumbnail
and and i think sometimes we confuse
what's actually the important part of
that the important ingredient
and i think if you're just getting
started out like copy my style do like
whatever it is so then you can learn
but you're probably not going to be able
to build an audience doing the same
thing that i
did just like casey neistat or peter
mckinnon and other youtubers that i
follow like
if i did exactly what they did i
probably wouldn't be successful well
it's interesting it makes me think about
how in other countries we have
like in portuga and brazil there's a
portuguese minimalism website that
someone has literally
copied and pasted everything that we've
done and they just have put it into
portuguese
and they have called it their own and
guess what they're not as successful
as us and that's for a couple reasons
like one
um they're not josh and ryan they're not
as awesome as us
but no really even if let's say you do
mimic someone perfectly
then like you said josh when someone
notices that oh
this person is mimicking the minimalists
then they become
a bit of an off brand like they don't
they don't uh
they're not as well regarded as as you
and i
uh maybe people do read their work and
they're great and it's great that it's
in portuguese and i'm actually grateful
that someone did that just so our work
can be you know
translated into portuguese but as soon
as someone sees like oh this is just an
off-brand josh and ryan
um that is going to prevent them from i
don't know being successful or
getting the credit that they could be
getting by doing their own work even if
they blew up though
because i know i know some people who
have literally like taken the scripts
from my videos
and then done it themselves um and then
they've even taken the identical
thumbnail and like everything they've
copied it verbatim yeah and they have
like big followings like they're
overseas they speak a different language
but they have five hundred thousand
to a million views on these videos that
are my videos that you're recreating but
not telling anybody
and i think it's dirty i think it's
great and i don't think that that's
right i don't think any creative should
should steal somebody's work
um but like like is he happy
like were you happy i like you know what
i mean like i don't
do it for the numbers i do it because
like i love making those videos and if
you want to steal it
go ahead but that's not gonna make you
happy at the end of the day yeah i mean
you're it's really
your own unique creations that are going
to make you happy
um well here's here's my pithy answer
pithy answer for mason
success without adding value is
failure so focus on adding value and
we'll talk about it in the maximal
episode but that's matt how i think
about your career like you found ways to
add value
and um you continue to do that and that
is why you are so successful
the other thing i was thinking too
there's something about um
there's something about there's
something pithy with uh
success has nothing to do with metrics
it has
something to do with a feeling so
success is a feeling not a metric
yeah yeah i mean it all depends on how
we define success and one of the
problems is we're chasing happiness
and you're chasing happiness there's
always a discontent so you're asking if
that
that guy's happy who's making the you
know the mattiavella
videos in russian or whatever like
he he probably isn't but he's also
probably chasing it
yeah and that's probably why he isn't
actually he's seeing what matt's doing
and just copying
that's not to say that you shouldn't as
matt said be inspired by people and in
fact
even take their recipe and tweeze out a
few ingredients
the thing that's worked in ryan and i
always go back and credit the people who
inspired us early on joshua becker leo
about
courtney carr for colin wright or even
with this podcast we've got
yeah we've got the love podcast and
we've got rogan and we've got a lot of
people who we took ingredients from
yeah yeah and so when whenever we we do
something
you can attribute it and and have your
own ingredients but you're creating your
own
new recipe and that's what matt has
obviously done with
his filmmaking and i totally agree with
you ryan it's really
ultimately if you're if you're not
adding value
you can't be successful you're not going
to feel successful yeah
speaking of adding value before we get
into that added value segment today we
have some listener tips but first
it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week matt like
why did you choose netflix over the
other platforms to release
les is now is phil if wait if filmmaking
had not worked out for matt
what would he be doing instead uh what
do you plan to do for your next film
project i'm imagining matt would uh open
up a pasta shop
that's an inside joke but we will let
you in on it uh during the maximal
what are your favorite lines that didn't
make the film
what are your favorite lines from the
film as well why did matt wear the same
t-shirt for three years straight
plus a million more questions for matt
diabella and the minimalist and if you
want to hear all that subscribe to our
maximal episodes on the minimalist
private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast and it's the
most honest way for the minimalist to
earn an income because we don't do
advertisements by the way if you're not
a
private podcast supporter you're
literally missing
two thirds of our show plus hundreds of
hours of past private episodes so try it
out for a week or a month it's cheaper
than a cup of coffee
head on over to the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi this is rachel richards and i'm from
the dallas texas area and i just wanted
to give you guys an idea
everyone always asks you know what to
give for gifts because they don't want
to you know
add to someone else's extra stuff you
know
and so um i came up with an idea of
making videos for my family
and posting them on facebook and they're
they're usually funny videos
and that's their birthday present from
us and they love it they absolutely love
it and they could share it with their
friends and
it's just been a big hit and it's free
and it's kind of like how you know
giving the experience but
especially if you can't be with that
family member on their birthday it's
really it's cool
this is cecilia duffy from geneva ohio i
have some tips for helping to minimize
your food preparation to keep things
healthy
yet not taking time daily to cook this
opens up time to pursue those things
that you value
i'm recently widowed and my daughter is
away at college so it is only me to cook
for most of the time
due to my life change and challenges i
am working longer hours to support
myself and daughter
as a chiropractor a core value of mine
is to eat healthy and organic
but i don't want to take the time to
cook on a daily basis like i did when i
worked part-time and was feeding my
family of three
on sunday mornings i put on the newest
podcast of the minimalist
and head to the kitchen to cook for the
week it takes me less than two hours to
cook for the week
and clean up the kitchen this will work
for those who don't mind eating the same
thing for a week at a time
for breakfast i cook up turkey sausage
and have fresh fruit available
other breakfasts include my homemade
granola with almond milk and nuts
for lunch this is where i get my daily
greens i use a very large tupperware
container and place
washed lettuces radishes shredded
carrots cukes
olives etc all ready to go i top this
salad with prepared proteins
i cook up lean proteins like chicken
turkey and fish
enough to last for all lunches and
dinners for the week
i buy enough to allow four ounces per
serving i figure out how many times i
plan to eat out that week and adjust
accordingly
for dinner i make ahead tons of roasted
steamed or sauteed vegetables
i will make one starch a week to eat
with dinner rotating between rice
quinoa pasta or sweet potatoes other
times i will make a large pot of soup or
stew that incorporates all the food
types
a protein starch and lots of veggies for
snacks i make a homemade trail mix with
raw nuts
raisins dried cherries and apples celery
with almond butter and raisins is
another favorite
nut or granola bars also work for snacks
all foods are placed in separate
containers in the refrigerator
i use a stainless steel container with a
bpa free lid
called lunch spots i buy only what i
need for the week
this keeps costs down and i don't have a
lot of unused food sitting in a pantry
when my daughter is home from school i
just increase the amounts that i cook to
accommodate
feeding her as well all right y'all
thanks again to matt diabella for
joining us today
thank you so much for having me this is
fun i don't do a lot of podcast stuff so
yeah it's great to have you guys yeah
it's awesome happy man you just started
something called uh
slowgrowth.com slow growth academy can
we talk about that for a second
oh my god this was my big project for
the year it was something that i had
been talking about doing for a very long
time
um you know i make these videos on
youtube that are usually around 10
minutes long
and they usually dive into different
narrow aspects of certain topics whether
it's personal finance or habits or
productivity
and so what i wanted to do with slow
growth
and i was able to to bring on my brother
hire him full time and as well as my
wife natalie to help build this company
was to create really intentional
thoughtful
courses um that help dive deeper into
these topics that i'm really passionate
and interested in
and so the first course that we launched
was on habits it's called simple habits
and it guides people
through how to build habits for
themselves it really pulls
primarily on my experience but also
dives into the science of habit change
and and
how change really works and you know i
i'm somebody who
grew up like always struggling with
being the smallest
kid in school always struggling to put
on weight build healthy habits build a
successful business
and i found myself stumbling and
stumbling and it was through the trial
and error that i was able to figure out
what was working and what wasn't working
and also just reading a lot of
books and and and people who have helped
to put me on that right path and so
that's the first course the idea isn't
to have a course platform like slow
growth academy is the course platform
and then simple habits is our first
course but the idea isn't to have
hundreds and hundreds of courses
uh it's really probably one or two
courses a year but really thoughtful
really intentional
i wanted to do something different and
really bring high production value
cinematography to courses in a way that
hasn't been done before and isn't done
often online
and i'm really proud of what we've
created and we've been getting some
awesome feedback from people so far
and for me and i know you guys know this
firsthand like the
the the biggest feedback that i get is
when somebody tells me that it's helped
them
or that they're hey 30 days in or i'm 40
days in and i've been running every day
and i'm building these habits
and um you know habit change and
lifestyle changes are not a straight
line there's so many ups and downs
and so um being able to build something
that could potentially
help people to get where they want to go
has been very fulfilling now if i sign
up for this
will you teach me how to have biceps
like yours that's some people people
have been requesting this
may or may not be working on simple
biceps
yes that's awesome yeah all right check
it out slowgrowth.com for our added
value this week
uh might as well just talk about matt
diabella's youtube channel yeah
um man i'm really proud of what you've
done man i really am
just so proud to see what you've done
the last three
four five years i'm proud but i'm more
jealous than proud
that's your own ego yeah absolutely i i
it couldn't have happened to a better
person and the work that you've put in
and you create these beautiful
meaningful
mini documentaries that are like nine
minutes
regularly if not every week i mean doing
a nine minute documentary a month is
in the the quality of your work so i
would just encourage folks to check out
your youtube channel thank you that
really means that it's awesome we'll put
a link to it in
the show notes uh real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
and also in the life of matthiavella
go watch less is now go watch matt's
film
it's on it's on netflix uh you can check
it out there we'll put a link to the
trailer and the show notes how have you
been describing this film to people
oh i mean you know since it's changed so
much
so much we we kind of sometimes get
stuck in the original version of it but
it really is a documentary and i know
that you you might call it a
docu-special
because there is this element of you
guys just telling your story straight to
the camera
but but really it's it's a documentary
that's that's what it feels like
it dives so deep into your guy's story
but it also talks about the culture that
we live in
in general and also how to work our way
out of this consumer cycle that we're in
if i could describe it in one line
and we'll expand on this during the
maximal it's
irwin is in the film or irwin mcmanus
and he has this line toward
uh well the middle-ish in english and he
says i think everyone should be able to
etch a sketch their life
yeah and if you were to i mean you need
a
a tag line for the film i think it's
that
yeah here's how to etch a sketch your
life
and i mean i love it there's so many
lines that didn't make the film that i
loved as well because we had so much
stuff we'll be talking about that in a
moment
i before i was sort of treating it as a
sequel and a prequel to minimalism it's
neither because documentaries don't
usually have
prequels but like in a way it kind of is
that so i encourage you to check it out
it's called less is now it's on netflix
uh this friday january 1st 2021. you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram
at the minimalist you can follow matt
diavel he's at matt diabella
at italian stallion on my space we need
to come up with that twitter handle
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalist dot com slash tour
to find a city near you if you have a
question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes and your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
the
minimalists.com you'll receive our
simple sunday emails as well
and if you leave here today with one
message we hope it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time thank you
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it